and now joining us on c-span is Ashley
Vance who's a technology reporter for
Bloomberg Businessweek and is also the
author of this book Elon Musk
Ashley Vance how did Elan musk become
Elon Musk well you know through a long
series of incredible invents he is he
sort of lived the American dream in a
lot of ways he came to the United States
with nothing about $100 in his pocket
and essentially these were basically hot
out works out hustled and and out
invented just about everyone in his path
what were one of his first inventions or
investments or successes his very first
success was this company called zip - it
was kind of a Google meets Google Maps
meets Yelp before any of these things
existed it was it was around 1994 and
essentially I mean it was the answer to
the age-old problem of kind of how do I
find a pizza place near my dorm room and
you know you would just type in I want a
pizza and it would show you where the
place was and give you turn by turn
directions and nothing like that existed
at the time and he ends up selling that
company for about 300 million dollars in
Elan was the largest shareholder and so
that's what really set him on his way it
gave him about 20 million dollars to
then go do whatever his heart desired
and what did he do with that 20 million
dollars well the next thing he did was
he decided he kind of sat back and
thought for a little while of industry
that needed a kick in the pants I guess
and he had worked at a bank as an intern
and he'd come away from that experience
thinking bakers were sort of dumb and
and and that they were kind of a herd
mentality and so again this was the
early days of the internet and he
thought to do basically an online
financial system for everything credit
cards your savings your banking and this
was called XCOM and then it morphs into
PayPal which I think a lot of people
have heard of so exactly
Peter Thiel is often cited as the
founder of PayPal what was Elon Musk's
role
well they were there both you know
co-founders in a way there was XCOM
which was elands company and then
literally in the same building there's
another company called con Finiti and
that was Peter Thiel's company that he
had started with another Stanford
graduate named Max Levchin and so you've
got these two companies in the one
building that were kind of spending each
other to death to compete to get in this
online payment space and they would
tempt people the user service by giving
them $10 if you could get a friend to
sign up and there was a lot of fraud and
so they decided to join forces and con
Finity comes up with this this service
called PayPal which was a way for people
to pay for auctions on eBay and that
becomes the big hit and then the company
just changes its name to PayPal now you
say Elon Musk arrived in this country
with $100 in his pocket where is he from
what's his background he was born in
South Africa and you know half his
family is Canadian American and the
other half is sort of British South
African he was a lot like you might
expect he was a precocious kid he read
tons of science fiction he was very
bright but he was a bit of a I kind of
know it all I mean he was he was he was
well-loved with his family but he was
bullied at school and when he wasn't
bullied he was kind of a loner he was
ignored by his peers I interviewed tons
of kids that he went to school with and
they all said pretty much the same thing
which was that you know he was just the
last person they would expect to to end
up doing all the spectacular stuff he
was he just kept to himself and and he
was really into computers and and the
sci-fi and that pushed him and and then
he'd always heard about Silicon Valley
and dreamed of getting to America and so
from a very young age that's what he
pined to do and at 17 he just ran away
from home and did it and ran away from
home he did run away from home had
Canadian citizenship and so he wanted to
get to the United States but he had to
sort of make this pit stop in Canada and
he sort of backpacks around Canada for a
year working a bunch of odd jobs and
he and then he gets into Queens
University and really starts to kind of
excel academically and then he ends up
at UPenn in the United States to finish
his degrees and what did he study at
UPenn he did a mix he did physics and
business at the same time he did those
in a combination did he do that on
purpose he did I mean he fancies himself
a physicist he was into things back then
like batteries and ultra capacitors and
all this and then he wanted to get the
business degree as well and and so he
does them both at the same time I think
it took him about five years and then
he's also hosting these big house
parties on the weekend to pay his way
through school they would have hundreds
of people show up at these gatherings
and and Elon would charge about you know
20 to 50 bucks a head for these parties
you write in your book that Musk's
behavior matches up more closely with
someone who is described by
neuropsychologists as profoundly gifted
that's right it's a clinical term that I
ran across as I was doing the book I
mean he is a lot of people think he's
they would say he's somewhere on the
Asperger's spectrum he doesn't seem to
show a lot of empathy towards his his
coworkers but you know I found that
there's a certain kind of person who at
a quite a young age has an empathy not
for individual people but for sort of
mankind as a whole it sounds I don't
know sort of fantastic and some people
but the he feels like he has to help the
human species there's there's a flaw
with the human species and he is out
there to help people as a whole after
the selling of PayPal what happened next
well he there's essentially a coup he
goes off on a honeymoon he's been
putting off his honeymoon for a long
time with his first wife Justine Musk
and there's a coup while he hops on that
plane to go to Sydney for the Olympics
and gets thrown out there's a big
disagreement over the direction of the
company and then a few months pass and
eBay
ends up acquiring PayPal for about 1.5
billion dollars
and Ilan ends up with 200 million
dollars and then you know he decides he
wants to do this grand gesture for
mankind he goes to the NASA website he
sees that there's kind of nothing there
about exploring Mars and this really
depresses him he's always been into
space and so he decides he is going to
send at first mice to Mars and then he
decides he wants to send a plant that's
going to kind of to supply the first
oxygen on Mars and we would watch this
in a video camera and was that
successful he never quite gets there he
he goes to Russia it's one of these our
basic stories he's got to buy the
Rockets and so he goes to Russia to got
to get these intercontinental ballistic
missiles refurbished ones on the you
know the brush is the only place he can
buy these the Russians treat him sort of
like just a dot-com millionaire that
they can take advantage of they try to
overcharge him they don't really take
him seriously and then he comes back
from that trip and he decides look you
know what I have to do is is build my
own rocket so that's the only way I'm
going to do this and this is kind of
where his company SpaceX is born around
2001 it is this idea that they're going
to be the the Southwest for space he's
gonna assemble Rockets much cheaper than
other companies and he's also going to
assemble them faster and really sort of
put the aerospace industry on it's on
his head
what has SpaceX accomplished or done
since 2001 it's been on a pretty
remarkable run I mean it's is this
really unlikely story that it exists
it's competing against entire nations
it's had a rocky beginning I mean when
Elon first started in 2001 he thought it
would take a couple years to get a
rocket up it ended up taking about six
or seven years and since then you know
it's not a space tourism company it's a
it's a commercial satellite company they
take satellites up for four countries
and for other companies communications
companies and the they have become the
low-cost provider in the market they
charge about
on the order of 30 to 60 million dollars
per flight versus hundreds of millions
of dollars for the competitors quite
recently they got on a really good run
of about one launch per month very
consistently and then unfortunately a
couple weeks ago they had their first
rocket blow up in a really long time is
it profitable SpaceX profitable Elon
says it is but it's private and so we
don't know for sure we do know they have
a backlog that they publish on their
websites and it has about eight billion
dollars in orders over the next five
years and so I mean it's a success story
it's they build a rockets in the United
States from scratch they use American
engines of their own design they're the
only American company right now that
that has American engines with the other
companies rely on Russian engines and so
you know they employ thousands of people
it's a it's a fascinating story it's
probably kind of my favorite one in the
book Ashley Vance what where is SpaceX
based where are the manufacturing
facilities it's based in Hawthorne
California which is just a few miles
from LAX they have an enormous factory
there about 500,000 square feet and it's
growing and they they they make
everything right there they have another
test facility where they test the
Rockets in Texas in McGregor Texas kind
of Central Texas and then they're
building a spaceport on the east coast
of Texas so what is Elon Musk's
relationship with Silicon Valley he's
kind of a unique character he so he
lives a very unusual lifestyle he has a
house in Los Angeles in Bel Air and
that's kind of his home base and that's
where SpaceX is based and then Tesla
Motors his electric car company where
he's also the CEO is based in Silicon
Valley they have an office in Palo Alto
and then they also have a factory in
Fremont California and so he splits his
time every week going back and forth
between the two and then he's kind of
this you know most of the Silicon Valley
CEOs I'd say they got to keep to
themselves they they're very much
married to Silicon Valley and kind of
the tech lifestyle you
a little more of like a Hollywood kind
of guy I mean he enjoys hanging out with
celebrities he's supposed to be moat the
story this Tony Stark type figure from
the Iron Man shows and he kind of revels
in that a little bit and so you know
he's a he's he's more of a celebrity CEO
that we've seen in a long time
who is Talulah Riley well to Lulu Riley
is this second wife this gets a little
complicated for everyone he's been
married and divorced and remarried and
divorced from her she's a British
actress and and then now I understand
that Elan it's hula our back together
again
his first wife he had five boys with and
then Tallulah is a second wife he met
her around 2008 when his companies were
were kind of going under world not going
under but was going through really tough
Financial Times and she sort of stuck
with him during that and his
relationship currently with Justine I'd
say it's you know they share custody of
their kids and I guess they it's I would
say it's just a little bit strained
although they share custody with the
kids and and and sort of work that out
now you describe your book mr. Vance as
before Elan and after Elan what does
that mean right well yeah I had done a
cover story on Elan him for Businessweek
in 2012 and and had sort of gone to him
after that and asked him will not asked
him but I told him that I wanted to do a
book and he had he told me you know he
wasn't really going to participate he
was he was gonna either do his own book
or he just wasn't gonna cooperate and I
spent about 18 months you know really a
couple hundred people and enough of them
and just sort of pursuing the book
anyway and over time a bunch of those
people go back to him and ask him if you
know they should talk to me and and then
one day I get a phone call from I'm at
home it comes up on my caller ID Elon
Musk and he said look I'm either going
to participate with the book now at this
point or really
make life miserable for you and we kind
of hashed out terms over a dinner where
he would participate and and he didn't
get to read the book even though he sort
of asked here he wanted to put footnotes
in it and have some influence but you
you know ultimately I said I kind of
couldn't live with that and then he
agreed to do interviews over about eight
months from there on out and how many
sessions did you have with him well we
met basically once a month over those
eight months and they would go anywhere
from like an hour to three or four hours
at a time and then he also gave me
access at that point to his executives
at his companies and then I would go
with him to Tesla and to SpaceX and we
would walk around the factory we'll walk
around the Tesla design studio I'd sort
of go to like a movie premiere with him
and sort of got to see how he operates
what is his reputation and what did you
take away from the factory visits what's
his reputation as a CEO well you know
it's complicated he I think in Silicon
Valley
he is completely seen as the next Steve
Jobs he's the guy that all the young
kids want to be like he is doing kind of
bigger bolder things certainly than a
lot of these you know app and web
service companies
he's reputation as a very hard charging
guy he demands a ton of his employees a
six-day Work Week is pretty standard at
both SpaceX and Tesla
he's very difficult to deal with for for
competitors and for suppliers you know
he's always putting them under intense
pricing pressure and time pressure
employees it's the same sort of thing I
mean he gets their inspired he gets a
ton out of them but he's very hard on
that maybe he's been known to really go
at people during meetings and to be
pretty relentless to get them to solve
problems and and on the whole I mean my
takeaway was that he's kind of the most
he's definitely the most intense human
being I've ever met as we're taping this
in the middle of 2015 how
Lizzy he's 44 he just turned 44 and
unfortunately his birthday present was
one of those rockets blowing up did you
leave this project as a fan of Elon Musk
that's another complicated question you
know I went in I went when I first
started I mean I thought he was a
one-note sort of guy like a techno
utopian type figure and I came away
discovering he is a much more complex
character I mean he's just said you know
I think you could easily argue he's kind
of lived one of the most interesting
lives of anybody going and he's was very
complex man I think I came away I came
away thinking that I'm a fan of the
companies absolutely I mean I think
Tesla is changing the automotive
industry
I think SpaceX is changing the aerospace
industry his third company Solar City is
a solar panel installation company and
they're doing very well and so I'm blown
away by the technology I think Elon is a
work in progress I mean I think he
there's a lot to love about him and
there's a lot of stuff that's very hard
and so you know but I still to me he's a
guy who Silicon Valley talks a lot about
disruption and I'm kind of cynical about
it I don't see companies that are really
pushing that hard on the status quo but
I think Elon is and to that degree I'm
absolutely a fan of what he's doing you
mentioned Tesla how did the Tesla
factory end up in Fremont California
that's an interesting story as well I
actually was a proper car manufacturing
facility there from the from GM and
Toyota they had a partnership that dated
back many many years it was supposed to
be the best of both worlds you had sort
of Japanese manufacturing expertise
along with kind of American ingenuity
and and know-how and and they were going
to combine forces and then during 2008
when the recession hit it was one of it
was an asset that had to go for these
car companies and Tesla was looking for
a factory and so they
they really got it on the cheap but they
this factors probably normally be worth
billions of dollars they they got 450
million dollars including you know it's
basically an investment from Toyota in
the company and how many people they
employ tell us about the factory today
yeah absolutely I mean the you know it's
not it used to pump out hundreds of
thousands of cars and so it's not filled
to capacity right now Tesla pumps out
about 50,000 to 60,000 cars a year they
have this Model S sedan which is a
luxury sedan that costs on the order of
a hundred thousand dollars for most
people they're about to come out with
the second car called the Model X which
is kind of an SUV and they employ
thousands of people there they're
probably on the order of around 10,000 I
think and then the numbers getting even
higher they're over in opening this
enormous battery Factory in Nevada which
is also scheduled to employ thousands of
people in the coming years Ashley Vance
you write that for musk going public
represented something of a Faustian
bargain what does that mean you know
Elon likes to as in the case of SpaceX I
mean he's taking this very long term
view and I think Tesla is the same sort
of thing he had to convince people of
electric cars they have to build things
like these network of charging stations
all across the world he's got to build
this battery factory it it asks a lot of
investors in the company to continuously
buy into the idea that that he's going
to gamble billions of dollars again and
again and again and and so it was you
know he needed to raise money at that
point in time for the company to build
its factories and so he had to go public
and then but that put him under this
immense pressure and scrutiny that Elon
really doesn't like he prefers to kind
of operate with a little bit of secrecy
around him but essentially the company
had no choice that was around was coming
out of 2008 and and the company really
needed money at that point
Hyperloop what is it we don't know for
sure yet the you know it was announced
this thing a couple years ago I mean it
a monorail type thing it would be too
raised platform with these pods that
travel on a bed of air and and Ilan's
version of this the the pods would go
800 miles an hour so you could go from
LA to San Francisco which normally would
take five hours by car you would go in
30 minutes it's all hypothetical at this
point is essentially a drawing on paper
Elon was upset about the the California
high-speed rail project he thinks it's
kind of expensive and slow which I guess
it is and and so he offered this up is
an idea for an alternative he really
isn't looking to commercialize it
himself although three two or three
companies have since appeared that that
are there's essentially Hyperloop
startups they've they've taken the ideas
that he put out there they're looking to
buy air rights one is trying to go
between Los Angeles and Las Vegas and so
the ideas that you'd be able to do that
in 15 minutes and so you could leave LA
go to Vegas for the night and come back
and sleep in your bed now your book has
been on the bestseller list for a while
have you heard any feedback from mr.
musk I did you know when so he didn't
get to see the book before it came out
but I did let him see it once it was
finished a couple weeks before I didn't
want him to have to buy it on Amazon and
kind of speed read it and it seemed like
the fair thing to do and so he went
through it and and kind of as you might
expect he he sort of pushed back on a
few things or at least was a little bit
at least giving me his feedback on them
and then you know a day later he came
back and he told me he well he told me
it was well done and he told me it was
very accurate he gave me a 95 percent
accuracy rating and and then so we sort
of left it at that and went on with
business as usual now you compare and
contrast him to Steve Jobs Bill Gates in
a couple other Silicon Valley or high
tech guys give us a sense of what you
what you say in the book yeah well you
know he in Silicon Valley today I mean
he is seen as this next Steve Jobs kind
of figure I actually and there's bits of
him like that for sure
he's got this attention to detail he
pushes his workers really hard I mean I
tend to lean more it's a sort of this
this Edison kind of idea although I
think Elon has a lot to prove but what I
really taken away is that he's a guy who
gets these thousands of engineers at
both SpaceX and Tesla kind of the
brightest of the bright and and these
these very hard-working individuals and
really is able to to get products out of
them that can be commercialized and that
have really changed industry if you look
at to me he's the guy who has he's
combined software and hardware this idea
of atoms and bits you know in a way that
nobody else has he's kind of changed the
car forever it's a computer on wheels
now and all the other automakers are
scrambling to match the software in
space he's taking consumer electronics
and software and really changed the
economics of space travel and and so I
see him as this industrialist more on
the order of sort of an Edison I think
certainly he's got to get something like
a mainstream electric car a reusable
rocket to kind of be in that ultimate
Pantheon something else that Elon Musk
is proposed is the launching of the
satellites and low altitude to increase
internet speed yeah it's this idea of
like a space Internet I guess is what I
call it you would surround the earth
with thousands of satellites in a low
Earth orbit most of the communication
satellites they're much higher up and
they have a pretty the latency of
sending the data back and forth is not
really good enough for Internet service
and so it's only recently we've gotten
to the point where we can make these
kinds of satellites and people have come
up with ideas how you would arrange them
and so you would send up these thousands
of satellites there it would sort of
serve a couple different functions one
is there's about three billion people on
the planet who probably will never be
served by fiber-optic cables it's just
too expensive or too hard to get it to
them and so for the first time they
would have sort of fiber-optic
equivalent speeds delivered from space
and then it would be essentially a
backup internet anything that went wrong
with fiber cables on the earth you would
have this space Internet as a backup and
it could also be
used to sort of deal with huge amounts
of traffic that gets sent say between
North America and Europe
SpaceX who's looking to build the
satellites and send them up through a
partnership with Google and then there's
another company called one web that's
basically their competitor and is a head
of SpaceX it's so far in this race so is
that project off the drawing boards is
it in planning at this point well you
know one web the competitor is is
they've got sort of designs for the
satellites they're very close to
beginning manufacturing and and to
sending up the satellite SpaceX is
coming from behind here I mean the Elon
just announced a couple months ago the
creation of a Seattle office for SpaceX
where they're gonna build these
satellites and and and it's early days
for sure and then the the other huge
question behind all of this is that like
in a good year SpaceX or Ariens boss
which is the European rocket come rocket
launch company in a good year they would
do one launch a month and two to get
thousands of these satellites up in
orbit we're talking about at least it's
kind of a launch a week or several a
month and and so there's huge questions
around kind of where this capacity is
going to come from especially it with
SpaceX kind of hitting a bump in the
road lately Ashley Vance
I wonder if Elon Musk took exception to
this paragraph which opens each facet of
Musk's life might be an attempt to sue
the type of existential depression that
seems to gnaw and his very fiber I don't
think he would necessarily take
exception at it you know he it goes back
to the thing we were talking about a
little bit earlier around the profoundly
gifted thing I mean he has a when we
would talk about the survival of the
human species that you have to remember
that the ultimate goal of SpaceX is not
just to send up satellites it's to
create a colony on Mars this is eelain's
overarching life goal I think for some
people it probably sounds really weird
but he thinks the human species needs a
back-up plan and he feels you know his
existential dread
that the human species will be wiped out
and and that we're not doing anything
about this and I mean I don't think you
would take exception with that at all
when we would talk he would break down
in tears at the thought of sort of man
being wiped out by by a virus or
something we haven't even foreseen marry
breath Brown who is she you know if
these comparisons kind of to Tony Stark
are true or you want to just indulge
them for a little bit she would be the
equivalent of Pepper Potts his his loyal
assistant she worked with him for about
thirteen years dating back to the PayPal
days and elands crazy life living in two
cities every week at the same time
working seven days a week she did all of
that she essentially gave up her life to
him she was his personal assistant his
work assistant she would handle media
things business decisions she was the
person that people would come to if they
wanted to go ask Elan for a lot of money
for a project they would come look at
her first and see you know if she gave
them the nod or the go away was Elan in
a good mood or a bad mood type thing and
you know over the course of ordering the
reporting of my book just just about 18
months ago she was basically let go from
the company why the story as I've heard
it from other people and from Elan
himself was that Mary Beth basically
asked for a raise and she wanted to be
compensated on the order of an executive
vice president at SpaceX and she had
this very weird role I mean it wasn't
there was no like one job title that
would really cover what she did and an
Elan told her you know to take a couple
of weeks off just to sort of clear her
head and then also he wanted to see what
life was like without her and when she
came back he said he thought he could
survive without her and
I don't think she took that very well
and that's a taste of Elon Musk Tesla
SpaceX and the quest for a fantastic
future written by Ashley Vance thanks
for being on c-span thank you so much
for having me